hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and this is Tamra's never seen and today
I am watching Indian in the cupboard
she'd be named Native American in the
cupboard but the 90s were a time I know
absolutely nothing about this film I
know it's a 90s film I know people say
it's weird but good is what I've heard
from friends and that's all that's it
was it Disney no right was this like a
movie that came into theaters was this
something that you watched on TV I have
no idea what this movie is at all
so anyways I'm excited let's do it okay
cover
[Music]
you
that was still armed also it's literally
it's just like it's an Indian in a
cupboard I thought that maybe I don't
know I thought it'd be something
else going up literally just an idiot of
the covered great again Native American
in that cupboard but the night I'm
Native American so I can say that make
that joke can make that observation
basically this story is just about this
kid named Omri who gets a magic cupboard
the magic key and can bring toys to life
and then it's him like very carefully
taking care of this small little Native
American and it's so odd this is like
that rabbit movie that I walked
watership down it's like that
where it's like this is a kid spell it's
pretty dark it's really dark for a kid's
film and I I honestly enjoyed it it had
more heart than I thought it was going
to have it's a little slow at times but
it ended I was like I think I mean I
think I got something from that it is
really beautiful
Arleen character Omri has a birthday and
his friend gives him a small Native
American plastic toy his brother just
like garbage picked this really cool old
cabinet and like that's a weird choice
for a present for your younger brother
but I want that cabinet his mom gives
him a key that somehow fits in this
cabinet and then his parents got him a
skateboard
does not matter at all filling in this
is what I'm talking about with kind of
dark moments though when the mom gives
him the key for the cupboard she's like
yeah I collect keys I have all my life
oh that one the one that you want the
one that fits well that was given to me
by my grandmother on her deathbed it's
the only thing I wanted from her you can
have it like super nonchalant like oh my
god this key was like the last thing you
got from your grandmother when she was
dying just like a little sprinkle
there's like some really
really intense stuff so Omri decides to
place his plastic Indian in the cupboard
and in the morning he wakes up but
you're scratching and for some reason
they the Indian is alive is it the
cupboard is it the key is it just armory
is it is it the small plastic figure
what is magical about this also what the
who is this bait for this is so weird
it's so weird and it's awkward and it's
still like a weird 90s film but you know
what it has a lot more heart than I was
expecting something like you know I
don't know Kazaam had nothing no heart I
feel for these characters at least even
though the the main boy Omri he's he's a
very he's an awkward cool dude but I
don't know he really truly cares about
this toy that's come to life and it it's
beat and I don't know a t-rex fights
Darth Vader so it's not all that bad I
really love the use of the cupboard and
like to bring things in he brings in
like a doctor he brings in a guy in
armor to take his hatchet they can make
wood or they can make a house it was fun
that's a fun thing that like as a kid
you're like yeah hell yeah I want I wish
that those were alive what a cool thing
to see as a child like what would I have
brought to life I don't know Power
Rangers
I'd be awkward though because I made
them kiss a lot and so to bring them to
life so I liked the use of the cabinet
and bringing more things to life until
they killed an old Native American Moe
pop and it's like okay well now we're
into murder so now this movie has taken
a turn we've murdered someone now we're
at that point then only pumps a rat he
said this this rat is in this like one
of those hamster wheel balls and and and
he punts it because he doesn't want him
to get his friend little bear and I said
well that's attempted murder Armory so
we're like we're we've gone way too far
and we're to the point of no return you
have to pump the brakes buddy you have
to simmer down
you cannot keep murdering small things
then Ollie shows his friend little bear
and his friend is like wow I want that
give me I want a toy to come til I give
it to me give me that toy thing do that
so they make a cowboy then there's a
cowboy and Indians is very like diono
Night at the Museum vibes a little bit
but that really just puts everything
into chaos
Omri what have you done his friend just
can't get his mouth shut it is like
trying to tell people and like doesn't
take care of his cowboy friends very
well there's like how voice says I
always cry I've got a soft heart it's
really sweet so then they take a deer
toy and they make it real so that little
bear can hunt and have food and then
they're also they're like gutting him
and then they're dealing with this this
racism between cowboys and Indians and
it's like addressing it in a lovely way
there's murder this movie is pretty real
for a kid's film honestly okay then
little bear tells Omri that he needs a
wife and like alright I met my
significant other on plenty of fish so I
can't really speak on on that or shame
anyone how they meet people but putting
your love life into the hands of an 11
year old that's that's uh some trust
that I will never have Oh God for the
day wrote what the hell little bear shot
the cow
the nut was a rat attack the key is lost
the cowboy is healed by the doctor
character again and they decide they're
going to send back the cowboy and little
bear it's it's a really sweet moment and
also Audrey is really open with little
bear about what happens to his people in
the future little bears like are my
people always a great people and always
like yes he's so sweet yes I talk very
lately almost always gonna weak moment
any time I'm just gonna weep it up you
know what I mean yes he's like oh but
something else happens cuz I think
you're gonna weep and always like yeah
things aren't always great for y'all he
still goes back to his life and she was
his cousin that he was helping and to
make a man and like it's just it's a
beautiful moment I'm gonna weep to uh
Marie I wrote so weird so much heart a
little awkward very sweet clumsy acting
lovely truths not Disney's I was that
weird off-brand dark Disney I have had
this on my list of things to watch since
starting Tamra's never seen and I put it
up on Twitter for a poll and it didn't
get that many responses so I think this
might just be more for me I don't I
don't know how well this is gonna do but
I honestly I really enjoyed this you
will be interested enough to search out
the book series which is so much more
magical oh Jessica I did not know that
there was a book series that's awesome
and I could so see this working so well
in Hawaii a series ah it's so cool oh my
god one of my favorite childhood flicks
this was my secondhand lions a movie
that I watched a million times
growing up for some reason okay you'll
probably have a been there done that
kind of reaction but you'll find a cute
story it's directed by Yoda no really
Frank Oz directed it did not know that
the scene with Darth Vader and Robocop
is cool so you might wonder why he
doesn't explore more possibilities with
the cupboard totally I wish they would
have put that way farther there was a
lot of very quiet slow scenes which made
it drag a lot more than it needed to I
feel like because everything else I
really enjoyed so that would have been
fun a lot of people are saying that it's
boring does drag its points but it has
so much heart that I just I don't know I
thought it was weirdly nice and just
wholesome and I love watching a good
wholesome flick you know on say you know
I mean that's right I'm wearing this
because I wanted to say I love hey
Arnold for that effect I love the
wholesomeness of Hey Arnold
and even if well no those are all
they're so beautiful and great there
weren't really boring ones but you know
even if there's one where something
crazy isn't happening it's just it's so
cute and wholesome it's like yeah I
won't I want to watch that I want that
energy in my life you know what I mean
speaking of wholesome next week I'm
watching Street Fighter can't wait for
that thank you so much for watching I
will see you guys next week
[Music]
[Applause]
you